guarda mai poi sto testando nuovo audio
che l'ultima volta che ho fatto video
così è riuscito a mezzo robotico e
scusate mi sto ancora cercando di
migliorare la qualità dell'audio però
pian piano sta migliorando avrò questo
microfono in faccia per tutti i video
però almeno non si sente da cani come
prima io ho sempre odiato queste cose
degli youtuber questa questo si chiama
il braccio a ragno ma anche già il nome
è una merda nuova che ragno praticamente
ti permette di spostare microfono e di
averlo davanti alla faccia in modo tale
da avere le mani libere di giocare il
vero problema di questa fa i veri
problemi sono due uno è che si vede nei
video che tu hai un microfono davanti
alla faccia la seconda cosa che sembra
anche un po brutto con scena la seconda
cosa è che io ho attaccato alla
scrivania questo rottamaio ferrovecchio
un rottamaio che è veramente ingombranti
simo però almeno nei video si sente bene
quindi
enjoy pensavo ragazzi da un pochettino
di fare questa reaction ai tic toc visto
che ho iniziato a fare i tic toc anche
io ma mi sto facendo con ciccio
ovviamente conoscete tutti stiamo
divertendo un sacco ragazzi volevo farvi
vedere per quelli di voi che ancora non
avessero visto questo mondo incredibile
che stiamo portando avanti e sta
piacendo tantissimo city fox spopolando
incredibilmente quindi vi ringrazio
voleva appunto farà reaction ha dei tic
toc che mi piacciono perché
effettivamente ce ne sono molti carini
secondo me le cuffie che subito ad
esempio non servono queste ragazze il
mio profilo se non mi seguite seguitemi
perché una volta mi chiamava mi hanno
potuto nickname poi mi hanno cambiato il
fai vj perché erano usciti un miliardo
di fake quindi va bè questo raga il mio
profilo e vedo con piacere che i video
più elaborati in assoluto sono quelli
che vanno meno come come sempre stato
anche su youtube e così quantify un culo
però il video quello che va meno per
quelli che ti fai in cinque minuti fanno
un sacco però vabbè abbiamo iniziato a
fare video con quello di the sims che
non so se avete visto ad esempio è
l'ultimo video che abbiamo fatto è stato
questo che ha fatto tantissimo sto
facendo un milione in un giorno
praticamente la parola
la allora adesso vi dico sta roba adesso
vi dico sta roba che se non ve la dico
io sono per avessi detto non l'avresti
mai capite r no questo ti toc ragazzi
sembra evitato perché il movimento di c
cioè e incredibile ma siamo
semplicemente noi che facciamo le
reazioni al contrario è talmente fatto
bene che la gente pensa che sia montato
c'e nei commenti la gente pensa che sia
montato invece se guardate i led vanno
tutti quasi sempre nella stessa
direzione quindi si vedevano l'abbiamo
riavvolto
abbiamo fatto benissimo però è un trend
ci abbiamo messo poco ha fatto un
milione invece i video che ci si mette
una vita a fare tipo questo
ha fatto 85 mila cioè peccato perché è
veramente se uno dei più belli dove il
movimento che io faccio dove devo
seguire per forza del personaggio che si
muove
è bellissimo per questa parte mi fa
piacere
perché ci sta talmente tanto nella posa
di link che escono e che conterà
veramente link
seguenti cioè veramente un talento
nell'imitare videogiochi noi non so come
dire comunque non è neanche il video
dove ci siamo lanciati di più perché in
realtà è questo qua
dell'amore di routine l'avete visto
proprio perché ha fatto un sacco tranne
sugli altri social ha fatto un sacco
praticamente abbiamo deciso di fare alla
fine questa scena dove io bevo il latte
questa poi arriva ragazzi allora
io
[Musica]
per te che la risata di ciccio
incredibili il suo video sembra una
damigella che ride abbiamo fatto
lasciare del latte alla fine perché io
vi assicuro e lo sapevo già io questo
che ho fatto social face mi lanciavo che
la metà basta quando tutti sporchi così
tanto di date poi puzzi di latte in una
maniera che fa veramente schifo
la da nausea una merlo continuate a
puzzare di latte per tipo due giorni è
stato orribile ha tutto per un tic toc
di 10 secondi non male come idea bond il
o queste tre questo è il trend di
lighting strange cioè dove tu non riesce
a fare un'azione
perché devi fare un'altra tasche prima
di farla se non ti si sblocca l'azione
con questa cosa qua vita è andata e il t
top che negli ultimi giorni ha fatto di
più perché ha fatto poi 2 milioni quasi
una settimana abbiamo tre minuti cioè
questo è uno di questi non è niente c'è
veramente i tic toc che ci abbiamo messo
di più a fare sono quelli che sono
andati meno quindi meno ci impegniamo
più facciamo ottimo però ragazzi
scusatemi se vi dico che questo il mio
preferito del primo che abbiamo messo di
questo di questo nuovo perché l'avevo
fatto di tik tok prima però è da un po
che che non ne facciamo qui da questa
nuova partenza di tik tok questo di the
sims secondo me è troppo fatto bene cioè
nel senso l'avevamo già fatto e non
avete visto guardatelo però questo
secondo me merita tantissimo non vi dico
che bordello è stato crowe pare questo
affare in testa a ciccio e a me ea far
sì che ci seguisse per tutto il video
non l'ha fatto già in questa roba fatta
io onore al merito già scusa
anche perché già non l'avrebbe fatta
così bene ei scherzo che lo monta visto
video poi sono cazzi miei questo video
di monto io no i teli mondo tutti stai
veramente tanto con i ragazzi ci stiamo
divertendo un sacco ci sono anche un
sacco di altri video che devono uscire
in questi giorni perché li stiamo
registrando le stiamo registrando
parecchi quindi seguite vi sul canale di
tik tok perché usciranno delle cose che
non avete idea che questo era niente in
confronto che i lidi nette sono molto
molto molto contento di aver avviato
questo progetto è porteremo avanti tutto
questo prossimamente quindi seguiteci
il momento di dirti chi ha deciso che
non era il momento lo sai chi
è
bellissimo rt pup sei e sarai sempre un
genio io dirò sempre
questa roba perché lì
lo spazzolino subito
mammamia chiellini ma cosa sto vedendo è
veramente una delle prove più kring che
io abbia mai visto chiellini che tenta
di recitare questo spot questa faccia
però c'è da dire che chiellini non ha
visto che in terapia perché se non si
sarebbe gridato lui non lo so se la b
spero che non lo abbia visto l'inter
quindi posso anche stare zitto
effettivamente andiamo avanti
no
scappa ma questo questa era un video di
franco bechis non l'avevo mai visti
video di frank sulle scorregge sui
politici neanche quelli sulla gente
perché sono i video più visti ma io che
sono sulla terra da quando visse gesù lo
conoscevo ovviamente per tutt'altro una
volta che facciamo gli scherzi
telefonici ma che pensavo sappiate una
volta mi ha chiamato frank non mi
ricordo per quale motivo pensavo mi
stesse facendo uno scherzo telefonico io
avevo riconosciuto al telefono mi ha
detto boni sta per fare uno scherzo io
so che lui però cosa devo fare lo stare
al gioco non capivo che se non mi fanno
ma non ti sto facendo uno scherzo una
chiamata seria non ho mai visti prima né
sentiti quindi boa incredibile con
questa cosa bravo frank è geloso o hai
preso stasia
ei può poi se poi non ho mai capito
perché in inglese devono dire per starci
a u
trip
che trip incredibile
come ha fatto
no vabbè lui è un grande no
ma è la faccia dopo che mi uccide non ha
senso va bè ragazzi questo era un po il
mondo che fa esplorando perché sono un
po partito da boomer ma spero di non
arrivare
devo fare una frase poetica ma intanto
non c'è bisogno oggi non ci è vietato
scorretti e fai le views basta spero che
gli sia piaciuto spero che l'audio sia
buono in questo video dove vi sono
attaccato al microfono per essere sicuro
che fosse buono l'audio quindi fatemi
sapere ci vediamo appunto anche su tik
tok gli altri social che vi lascio in
descrizione così ci seguite a me chi
chuan tv dove faccio la sopra che vista
la capraia atomica solo con ciccio ma
ultimamente ci stiamo divertendo un
sacco quindi diciamo ma nell'insieme
chiede al canale e noi ci vediamo come
sempre alle frazioni di belle ragazze
[Musica]